now what i want us to do is um even
though this looks really great
and we've answered by the way this
question that i wanted to have a look at
which one is it uh part c do you see
part c there
find the total value of the fund when it
is paid out on
the 1st of january 2041 right so you
just found that out it's this number
right down the bottom okay and if i mean
i can show you the the textbook answer
that's where they land
okay what i want us to do now is to see
if we can use this model to answer some
of the other questions okay let's have a
look at part d
part d says the person wants to reach a
total value of a million
in superannuation does this ring a bell
you remember we've done questions like
this before okay
now think for a moment don't touch your
keyboard i want you to process this
before we start
interacting with this how can we use
this spreadsheet
to find out when we get to a million
have a think about it
what might we do yeah we're trying to
answer part c
it says ah sorry a bigger part in part d
the person wants to reach a total value
of one million dollars in superannuation
currently i'm sitting at 630 and 24.99
what will i do to work out the eventual
point when i get to a million any
takers you have to make it equal to
millions
okay so i've got to get something equals
to a million now think about this right
when you were doing this by hand you've
got your formula for the sum of a gp
you put in all the right numbers and
then this number would be your answer
okay but now what serang is correctly
saying is
if i want to answer this new question
part d
i would make the answer a million and
then try and backward
solve right you have to find m okay but
i want you to think back
we don't have any sum of a gp formula in
here right
everything is using this um where my
cursor goes using this recursive method
so i don't have some like watch if i
just said oh let's make this thing a
million right
nothing happens right because it's i've
gotten rid of the formula right so
that's why it's now oh you want me to
say a million
fine the model is now broken okay so i'm
just going to undo that
i need a different way of thinking right
what are you thinking max
ah okay so b3 that's up here
right so what um what max is going on is
this
idea of do you remember when we talked
about don't worry if you don't remember
what it was but present and future value
do you remember this idea
so i'll come to you in a second sorry i
just want to make sure max's idea
gets some time here present future value
is this idea that future value is this
number we've ended up at
let's go down here right present value
is
how much would i have had to invest it
at the start just in one
lump sum so that i end up on this same
number without having to do many
installments
okay now that's a very interesting
question it's the question of present
future value
but i notice it is not exactly the
question they've asked me right they
have not
there's no language at least as far as i
can see about what's the present value
of my investment
for six hundred and thirty thousand et
cetera okay sarang
did you have a suggestion question what
do you reckon
remember when we said that you can't you
can't say equals something
like you can't on the same line you
can't say we've written equals already
all right yes
maybe a million equals likes b three
times four one ah okay so if and this is
the same thing that max was saying right
if i made i could just solve an equation
um
this cell here multiplied by 1.1 some
number of times
some number of years who knows right
gets me to a million right
the problem with that is that is not how
this situation works
that's imagining if i just put the money
in and then just sit and
and walk away but i'm not sitting and
walking away this whole column b
means i'm not sitting and walking away
what am i doing
i'm i'm putting more and more money
every time right
so let's try and think about this right
let me help you out
uh this is how much i end up with at the
end of 2040.
if i copy that whole row and if you're
in your spreadsheet i invite you to do
the same right
i've copied all three cells on the 21st
row
okay don't do it yet but what will
happen if i just hit paste on the next
row
what will the next row tell me
it should tell me the same thing but for
the next
year right every time you go down a row
you go down a year okay press paste and
see what happens
what did it do
yeah gives us the value for a new
payment and a new interest calculation
for 2041.
am i at a million yet no no but i'm
closer
i could just keep going right let's
let's do that right i don't have to just
add one row
i could add a bunch of rows there's
nothing stopping me the computer will
handle it all and you're like whoa whoa
i definitely overshot but you can find
the year where it happens right which
year is it 2045
2045 right um does it happen when we put
the investment in sorry the payment i
should say
no it doesn't happen at the start with
my investment it happens at the end you
can see
here this figure it's the interest
calculation you look at it by the way
look at it again
how much is the interest calculation
it's massive what is it
three it gets you up to it pushes past a
million dollars
and that shouldn't surprise us because
this is some astronomically large
interest rate right it was 10
do you remember that so 10 of nine
hundred and eighty three thousand four
hundred
it's ninety eight thousand three hundred
and forty seven
dollars and six cents i think right so
that's why it's so massive and it pushes
you over
okay so what we've done is we've just
modified our model a little bit the
question you just answered
is part d in fact we've gone all the end
the way to the end of part three see
that at the end of which year
will the superannuation be worth a
million dollars answer
done okay now um
then we're gonna do this last question
okay and then i'm gonna see if you can
have a go at the next one on your own
party can you read it with me
suppose instead that the person wanted
to achieve the same total
investment of a million dollars so they
still want to end up in a million but
they don't want to wait till 2045 they
want to get there in 20 years
that's the original length right so in
other words where are we at 20 years
we're here that one right there let me
highlight it
they want to get to a million dollars by
that time
so they're going to have to as the
question sort of implies
they're going to have to increase their
annual contribution do you agree
ten thousand dollars a year didn't get
them there you're gonna need to put in
more
okay so here's what we're gonna need to
do we're gonna need to modify our model
a bit i'm gonna show you how
um but watch closely okay
let's just say instead of ten thousand
dollars i wanted to make it
well why don't you guys give me a guess
ballpark figure
what do you think might be it doesn't
matter how wrong it's going to be
because the calculations are going to be
done by someone
fifteen thousand okay let's try fifteen
thousand okay now i wonder if you notice
our model
is not set up at the moment to make it
easy to adjust
that quantity from ten thousand to
fifteen thousand right
where do i have to change ten thousand
to fifteen thousand
where do i have to do it i have to do it
i have to do it in this row
because not ten thousand but then i have
to also do it in this row do you see
that
i gotta change that ten thousand to
fifteen thousand oh wait we're not done
i gotta change this ten thousand fifteen
thousand and this one
and this one's this can take forever
right we can do better than this
so here's what i'm going to suggest over
here on the right hand side
let's make a new little cell and let's
call it uh
actually let's call it payment because
um investment's sort of the whole thing
payment okay now at the moment
the payment that we do every year is ten
thousand dollars
and let's change that to i see what
you're doing
okay all right here we go so whoopsie
daisy i need to make that a bit bigger
there we go all right so what i'm going
to do is
you know how uh this cell it looks at
the previous one i didn't write down 21
000
i didn't type in 21 000. i just told it
to look at this cell which has 21 000 in
it
okay so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to say this number here
i just want it to equal whatever the
payment is
okay so you've written payment over
there on the right-hand side in a new
cell
and i just say yeah make that your
payment okay so at the moment when i
press
enter nothing should change right
because i haven't changed the quantity
is everything okay everything's okay
fantastic
but now here instead of saying again
plus ten thousand i'm going to say
don't write the number all over again
write
this guy over here do you see that so
that way i don't have to write ten
thousand again
or change it to fifteen thousand so i'll
hit enter and if i've done it right
nothing has changed
is everything looking okay on yours
thumbs up okay
now one of the things we did before was
we said once it established a pattern i
just copy it and i paste it down
okay so don't do this yet i want you to
watch carefully because something's
about to happen that you need to watch
closely
i'm copying this formula now if i did
this right
when i paste it everything should stay
the same i haven't changed to ten
thousand dollars
watch carefully and please don't do this
on your spreadsheet because
you'll regret it watch carefully
did you just see that oh i don't see a
difference
let me undo that this is what it was
before
this is what it was before okay look
carefully look at all the numbers
especially the one that i'm pasting and
watch what happens
hold on a second something something has
definitely gone wrong right
something has definitely gone wrong and
i can confirm that something's gone
wrong because if i scroll down
my number was like 600 and something
before right what happened now it's
5.74 right something's definitely gone
wrong so let's go back
i told you not to do this because it
would make something go wrong on your
spreadsheet i'm going to double click on
this cell because
i have you noticed double clicking shows
you the formula and i want you to tell
me
what's gone wrong
have a look closely
it added nothing why did it add nothing
i told it to add ten thousand didn't i
no ah very good now tyler's on exactly
the right idea here
you know how i went down a row right so
everything goes down a row
the blue reference you can see over
there c3 it goes down a row
the red reference also goes down i don't
actually want it to do that do you
notice that
it's gone off of the 10 000. okay so
here's what we're going to do we're
going to fix it
um have you got this cell in yours this
one you should already have right
this is b3 okay see how we don't want
the red cell to go
down we want it to stay put maybe some
of you remember
we've done this before instead of e3 i'm
going to write
e watch closely
dollar sign 3. now what that dollar sign
tells excel is
don't move stay where you are okay
when i move this when i copy and paste
stay put stay on row three so i'm going
to hit enter
and if i've done this right it should
actually work
if i paste it aha it's working and in
fact i can paste it all the way down
and you can see i'm getting the same
number every time does that make sense
put your hand up if you've got yourself
working with the dollar sign heads up
dollar sign dollar sign i see a few
what's happening not trying it or
you're too far behind okay that's fine
that's right
okay now what we're going to do is if
you have got the dollar sign working do
the entire column
go all the way because we want to
replace all of them
[Music]
okay right now moe's suggestion was
let's just try 15 000
okay now if we've done this correctly
all of them will change all of them will
change are you ready
go ahead and press enter did it work
now let's have a look um i'm looking at
this red number right did i get to a
million
it was not a bad i asked you to guess
right i got to in the ballpark
right i'm just like a couple years off
right so this is good
but i want to do better right now what
you can do is
you can just fiddle with this number
right maybe i make it fifteen thousand
and
one right and then you see if you get
there
like oh that wasn't enough a dollar okay
it's not gonna get there
okay um maybe you got ten dollars right
fifteen
thousand and ten
okay it's not enough right now stop
pause right there
eyes up eyes up
not that far up if you've already
fiddled around you'll notice
16 000 is too far i mean you know it
gets it gets to a million you're like if
i don't have to put that much in i
shouldn't right
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
show you something um that even i didn't
learn
until like i was like a proper adult
okay this this um
this fiddling with numbers and just
doing it like manually
why are we doing this we have a computer
here that's going to do things for us
right
so here's what we're going to do in your
um in excel and unfortunately if you're
not using excel here
i don't know what will be the exact
buttons you need to press okay so
hands up if you are on excel and it's
most of you right okay hands down
if you're on excel follow closely you're
on the home tab
up in the top right the home tab i want
you to go
over to the data tab if you're on
windows or mac it shouldn't matter
head over to data and what i want you to
find
is um there's a button up here i'm sorry
my
button is very small because my
resolution is behind
there's a button sort of most of the way
to the right it says what if analysis
can you find that button
um just give me a thumbs up if you
locate it what if analysis
yes a few not many though like two three
yes
have you guys got it yeah okay fantastic
go and press that and you'll see there's
a bunch of options there
right now the one that we want on mine
is the second one down it says goal
seek it's exactly what it says i've got
a goal
and i want to seek that goal so i'm
going to press that right there
okay
i'm on a mac so it should be there uh no
i don't sorry
you will find it but we'll have to dig
around for it okay
now here's what we want to do okay look
look carefully
at your new menu that's come up it says
set cell and then there's some cell that
you get to choose to value
and then lastly it says by changing cell
let me talk you through what that means
right there's some cell you want to
change to a particular you want to go
you want to be your goal right
what was our goal what are we after a
million dollars
when do we want a million dollars by
2040. now go
scroll down to where that is right for
me i highlighted that in red so maybe
yours is not as easy to find
but it's that one there there it is cell
c21 in fact i'm just going to write c21
whoops c21
now what did i want that cell to become
you already told me
i want it to be equal to a million right
i got there manually well done okay well
done okay
so i want c21 i want that cell to become
a million
and there's a single cell that i want to
adjust
to create that effect right which cell
am i changing
it's the one at the top right um i think
mine is e3 right
so therefore i'll just type e3 i'm going
to get excel to adjust that cell and
it's literally just going to test values
until i get a million dollars when you
hit ok
watch it watch the numbers actually
crunch did you get there
is that the number you got nail it
what i love is you can actually see
excel crunching it it tries it's like
it tries a little number then it tries a
bigger one and then eventually it gets
there
right say okay so you can see this is
the power of a model
right you don't have to guess at it you
don't have to do this by hand that's why
we put in the effort to understand all
these formulas
and such does that make sense yeah and
if the value is
ah very good yeah if you look closely at
the top here
if you zacky just raised a really great
point
if you take your cursor right you see i
can click on any cell right
if you click on the payment cell um up
in the top here in the top left
you've actually got more than just the
39 cents that it's rounded off to
you've got looks to me like uh 38.61568
etc
cents right which is an accuracy that i
think we were not willing to go and try
and find but excel can do it if you were
to invest that exactly
yeah it's like i don't want to waste
like come on i'm wasting
0.14 percent here and then some right
ridiculous